[Music]
[Music]
boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host Don sake on
very excited to be talking about the
value of art we have a Dahlia to miss
you ever joining us on the show hello
hello thank you so much for coming on a
deli
of course my pleasure very excited for
this for those actually that don't know
Adele yeah for what was it about two
years ago you made the really cool logo
that you can actually see on the
coasters that the course is designed the
coaster design Adalia made the coaster
design that you guys have been seeing on
the show for the longest time and her
art is just amazing I'm super happy this
is finally happening
Oh Delia is background also for those
who don't know is a designer artist and
dreamer who captures life's most
beautiful moments she's also an
organizer of beat art an art community
in San Francisco and you can find the
links in the bio below to seen and felt
calm as well as a Delia's Instagram I
tell you let's start things off by
talking about how you got interested in
art in the first place who were you as a
kid um sure let's start there so I've
been making art my whole life period I
think I started at four four years old
and my grandma she was just so
supportive she always said that I'm like
the most talented like person ever and
as a kid you just like grow up in this
you're like oh okay I guess I can do
something with art and that's support
that it went a really long way to get me
where I am today and I'm very easy so
I'm so grateful for my grandma's support
than that I grew up in Russia by the way
in Moscow it's a totally different
culture it's a different country it's a
different mentality to
and I am one of those people who felt
like I was born in the wrong place like
you know sometimes so you're born in the
wrong body you're born in the wrong
family I was born in the right body of
the right family but in the wrong place
and I just I always was obsessed with
America like I was just obsessed with it
the American dream was pretty much
everything to me I used to talk to
myself in English which is weird like
it's weird I'll be standing on my
balcony talking to myself in English I
learned English since I was six because
I wanted to move here and the reason for
it is really because I was so attracted
to this one American company that is
still like a North Star for me yes yes
that one company that I loved more than
any other company in the world and that
company is Disney yeah Disney I really
the first time I visited Disneyland was
actually in Paris in there's no in Paris
and it blew my mind it just you know I
was growing up making art and then I
entered the place where I was surrounded
by all this art made by these amazing
people and it was functional and it was
engaging and it was like a whole world
like it was a new world it offered me
hope it offered me just like it offered
me a new perspective on what you can do
with art and how you can change the
world and you can change somebody else's
day or you can change the course of a of
the world's culture really you know
which is what Disney eventually did you
you can barely find a kid who grows up
without Disney influence and America as
we know it today
is partially you know so it's it's so
like Disney culture has penetrated
American College is so much yeah
it just blows my mind to think about it
really yeah from when you're talking
about being a kid and having your
grandma be such a proponent of art in
helping you that's so important to have
like a family member or someone that can
be a like assisting what the kid is
passionate about to pursue that and then
also just like talking to yourself in
English on the balcony that's so funny
yeah I'm trade you're you know you
trained yourself to like follow a
passion at a young age and we're like I
know that I want to go to the United
States and you knew that you went after
Disneyland Paris like you know you go
and you see like you're describing
there's just such a crazy amount of
influence that Disney has had on kids
growing up in our world and I totally I
think what your another thing that
you're pointing out I think is that the
amount that like Walt Disney and all the
other designers and artists that have
been a part of that that organization
have made a lot of different stories and
they've made a lot of different designs
of characters exactly yeah yeah
storytelling is such a crucial aspect to
this because we perceive we learn in
stories you know and telling the right
stories is really really hard I mean
like think about it Pixar and Disney and
DreamWorks and Universal those companies
hired geniuses to tell stories something
that anybody can do but only few people
can do it really the right way and it's
it's really difficult to tell stories
that would appeal to different cultures
to you know that would be Universal that
would that would like an old person can
understand it and a young person can
understand it it's really hard to tell
those stories and somehow Disney does it
it just it fascinates me and it's such a
such an inspiration for me
you know like I'm trying to achieve that
point and it's one thing to tell stories
in in the media that is inherently
storytelling based like a video like
right now we're telling story but how do
you tell a story in a static form how do
you tell a story through architecture of
a place or interior design of a place
that is static there is no video of it
how do you tell a story through an
object or a painting or graphic design
of a marketing with material like how do
you tell those stories it's really hard
and it's an art of itself and that's
what I'm learning every day literally
yeah same same here when we're sitting
down with you know like 500 of these
different super smart people across
different fields we're taking what
they're telling us their stories and
we're trying to make this into one big
story this is a really fun to do and
it's also really hard and I'm like you
said there's geniuses that have been
hired into the the best companies
Universal Pixar DreamWorks Disney to be
able to do things like tell stories that
can be applicable to old people young
people rich people poor people people
from different religions different
places around the world all this type of
stuff and it is applicable it's
inspirational too and that's the thing
actually in many ways it kind of reminds
me of like a lot of like the religious
or myths mid the mythological
storytelling yeah absolutely yeah all of
those I mean like think about it Lion
King is like the Shakespearean story
right Hamlet I think yeah those stories
they have they're like fundamental
components but then the way you adapt it
to modern age and make people care again
is what really is tricky like how do you
make that third relevance today and yeah
and there are there are so many nuances
that go into
eating and compelling story because
there's like all the talents have to
align for the for one common goal and
how do you describe that goal exactly
you know you try to weed people right
like you are an entrepreneur you try to
lead people I try to lead my people my
community we know it's hard you know to
just like align people toward the same
goal and how did big companies do that
every like big companies they have
hundreds of thousands people working for
them how do they align all of those
talents towards the right the same goal
mind blowing they do it somehow that's
why that's that's why this they succeed
really they know how to do it yeah yeah
so lines were single and then also
you're giving the differences between
things like a story toeing through a
medium like video which seems to be in
this case a lot easier than if you were
to just make a static image or you know
like the interior design of a place for
the architecture of a building and try
and have that tell a story but we see
buildings that have taken you know
generations to build buildings that have
happened or that we've seen also like
the interior design of a building that
can tell a whole story about natural
light and about maybe as you walk
through you can see different aspects of
it so let's let's talk about you know
what were you doing then when you were
younger that then when you went to
Disney World was this aha for you that
you were like okay I know what I'm
dedicating my life to yeah
it is it is very it's very hard to
express it in words and I kind of wish I
could just invite you to that experience
which is exactly what I'm doing for my
art because it's so hard to explain in
words but it was this deep sense of
belonging you know when I went to so my
first ever place that I went to when I
came to the United States for the first
time
was just a tourist trip with my dad we
went to Walt Disney World because it was
my dream for so long and once I entered
Magic Kingdom I think it was the first
time I just felt like I belong there and
you know as I told you I felt like I was
born in the wrong country where I did
not belong unfortunately and how come
here I am in a foreign country with a
foreign culture foreign language that I
is semi speaking to myself but how come
I feel so welcome here and it's such a
warm environment and I feel most myself
as I have never felt before like that
feeling just stroked me and that it just
like it it penetrated my soul so deeply
that I couldn't shake it off like that
was pretty much all I could think about
ever since and that's why I really
wanted to work for Disney because I was
like how the hell do you design that how
the hell do you make people feel that I
would sell my soul to devil to work for
this place and and it is very important
to note that Disney is a very consumer
like they rely on consumerism and I it's
not like I'm anti-consumerist but I'm
not a consumer I don't see myself a
consumer when I go to Disney parks I
don't buy doll webs and bunch of Mickey
ears and all of that I don't do any of
that I don't have a single bad thing
from a Disney World
seriously I'm not a consumer I'm a
creator I'm a co-creator and I want to
be a co-creator of similar experiences
that Disney introduces into people's
lives you know yeah baby
yeah I I saw that that was a great
example of how you create experiences
that mean something to people and I
wanted to do the same and since that
trip I was 15 at that time that was my
goal like I want to work for Disney I
will do whatever it takes to
for Disney I want to work for Disney I
want to learn how they do what they do i
I want to make an impact and I came back
to Russia I brainwashed my family with
wanting to work for Disney and you know
one day my dad I guess he was doing
great in business or something so he had
some spare cash and he was like hey do
you wanna like study in the United
States
she asked me that and I was like yes it
was you know like it was everything I
ever wanted because studying in the
United States would get me closer to
working for Disney so I applied to 12
schools I think I got into all of them
except one I chose San Francisco because
it's in California and I got some
scholarship and then I I went to an art
school here in San Francisco Wow the way
that you expressed the the story of when
you land in in Disneyworld that there's
a feeling that you get that is like so
its expansive it's beautiful it's it's
it's like so many people put in so much
hard work in order for you to feel
something
exactly exactly I'm so glad you
mentioned that because there is so much
hard work that goes into it and you know
it you know you might not know anything
about architecture interior design or
Imagineering you might though none of
that but you know that somebody cared so
much but somebody dedicated their lives
working for this to bring you that you
know there is something so noble and so
like it just creates a community it
creates a community over this thing its
creators and consumers and they they are
a community which is the most beautiful
thing about Disney to me they have a lot
of people working for the company but a
lot of people receiving the gifts of
that work
which is like that exchange is just so
beautiful yeah and then now it's big
inspiration for you and now you're
teaching so many other people that how
can how can we make things that really
when somebody immerses themselves in the
experience of what we're showing to them
or what they're experiencing through our
art can we really move them so can we
really make something to them feel
something really powerful from within
like yeah that that is such an important
aspect to the things that we make and
like you said you're not there you know
consumerism buying the different things
you're there because you gain so much
inspiration and then you're out
co-creating the future yeah and I think
that's another huge component that we
definitely preach on the show as well so
I'm glad that's what you brought up
let's um
now let's yes so let's talk about then
as you end up I'm doing the actual
internship at Disney World and then also
yeah go ahead a little bit so I went to
school for five years
and on my final year I was applying to
Disney internships like crazy like crazy
I applied so many times I can't even
count I think I've lied twenty-seven
times like it was a it was the most
stressful period of my life because
that's literally like I came to this
country to do this and now I get like
rejected left and right because I can't
get an internship like it was very
humiliating almost you know it's like
I'm like I know I'm worth it like I know
I'm the right person please please give
me a chance and I think I apply 27 times
which is a lot a lot of rejections and
one of them worked out yeah you know one
internship worked out that's resilience
right there yeah you gotta yeah so then
I was so happy to accept it internship
and that internship happened to just
absolutely change my life just
absolutely it was the best thing ever
honestly the pay was almost non-existent
the pay was very low which is something
people don't realize about Disney
internships but the thing about it that
was so life-changing is that I got to
see the inside of how the company works
yeah and what motivates them and I
happen to be on the team that is
literally motivating other employees to
do good work and to create to make magic
for somebody else like I happen to be at
the core of what I wanted to be like I
just manifested it into my life like it
was it was yeah it was beautiful it was
a seven-month long internship and I
cherished every single moment of it so
much by the way it was in Orlando it
wasn't in California so I had to move
entirely and get a car and I got to
drive my own car on those like huge
Florida highways and experience
torrential rains and everything I fell
in love with Florida as I've never
fallen in love with anything else which
still very much impacts my all my work
just Florida and when I was doing my
internship at Disney I realized that I'm
not gonna stay I just realized that I'm
not gonna stay it's just not gonna
happen and not because they wouldn't
hire me but because of some combination
of things some paperwork didn't the
lineup I had a boyfriend in San
Francisco whom I really wanted to go
back to so I you know I knew that I
would be coming back to San Francisco
and I just realized that you know all of
this beauty all of this like hard work
that I've been working for is endless oh
and what is finite
oh it's finite yeah it's it's gonna end
it's gonna end
yeah okay because I'm not gonna stay in
the company you know like I realized
that oh but then but you took away so
much though to go and get inspired by it
yeah exactly exactly so it's technically
is
less than because you do learn so much
go and do it and I promise to myself
that you know once I work for Disney I
will never stop working for the same
values as what does nee stands for me I
will never stop doing that
I will I will always work for the same
values so basically in the middle of my
internship I was like okay I'm not gonna
stay so I've got to make the best out of
it like I got it just like absorb all
the vitamins from this internship and to
energize me for the rest of my life like
I've got to do it I worked for this way
too hard I got to do this and I was
looking for a way to to grab onto that
momentum you know that momentum it was
spinning it was evolving I was so on top
of my wave how do I encapsulate that how
I'm a designer I went to school for
graphic design I know how to think as a
designer and I decided you know what I'm
gonna encapsulate that feeling in an art
form so that are so that that feeling
lives on and on and on after I move on
and the I think the main piece can we
jump onto the drawing the first time so
this is where you started actually
piecing together with the initial
sketches and art piece that you were
trying to kind of like you were sponging
and dizzy you're like how do i Pratley
basically like how do I keep this as
yeah how do you do kind of want to like
keep it as like inspirational material
for you yeah put the practice in
yourself yes yes so I started doing
those planaria drawings in the park I
would go to Magic Kingdom and I would
sit right there and I would like sketch
out this French corner for example and
it would take me about an hour and a
half but what it provided me with I
trained my eye to see every single
detail because when you draw something
you need to see it first right and
oftentimes we don't see things we just
glance at them you're like you glance at
this palm tree and you're like it's a
palm tree I don't I don't need to look
but with this work you have to look into
every single detail so for me painting
this house for example I learned so much
about architecture just-just
architecture like you know exterior
finish and color scheming and
proportions I learned so much so that's
how absorb that that's a good way to
learn about the nuance exactly like
you've got a C and I think painting is
so beautiful because you have to see in
order to represent it properly you can't
just assume that it is that way no you
have to see in an in this slightly like
unbiased way so then another milestone
project for me was making a flower lamp
that was my first baby and I came up
with this idea at the meeting and it was
also like my endeavor of how do i
encapsulate this amazing feeling of
being on top of my wave and being so
inspired and I had this old IKEA lamp
that I absolutely hated because the the
light was so harsh and I was doing
felting at that time too so I was like
oh my god I can make petals like petals
for the flower and then I can
encapsulate at the top of the land so
that it just the devel disperses the
light so nicely and I came up with the
idea the meeting at work at about 2:00
p.m. then I couldn't wait to go back to
my home then I went back to my home I
spent 12 hours working on this baby I
felt it the whole thing by the way for
those who are not familiar with the
process this beautiful pink color comes
from avocado pits like you just boil
them and then you put wool felt into it
right you put wool into it and then you
boil it for another 30 minutes and then
it's pink like this what it's magic it's
magic yeah seriously so
learn stuff like that that's so trial
and error exactly let's boil avocados
and see if putting will wool in it will
make this color yeah I knew that from
school interesting
it sounds like first person that
discovered it I know people are so a
while yeah so I created this lamp and it
just it just stroke
today's did I say right stroke the cord
yeah yeah short for TIA
I was like this is this is it this in
this accurately translates how I feel at
this stage of my lives I'm moving right
now working for the company that I love
I'm blooming and I'm creating myself you
know like it's it's not a real flower
but I created it so I realized that I
can create my own future I can create my
own path it doesn't have to depend on
anything else I can create my own world
you know I don't have to grab onto being
attached to alders in the world or
Disney Company I can make my own world I
love that this was kind of like your
inspirational kick to go and take what
you learned and then go and create your
own exactly yes and Walt Disney just as
they you know as a character as a person
he is nobody is as inspirational to me
as Walt Disney because he made he
dreamed he dreamt a lot and he made it
happen so it's one thing to be a dreamer
you know it's like I could like wouldn't
it be nice to do this and that but like
you have to work hard to make it happen
as well and I work really hard on
finessing those lamps I know it's not
perfect it's far from being perfect and
I want it to be perfect you know like
this the stem is flimsy
and just generally I treat it as a
prototype so I went on to create all of
those other prototypes to advance my
technique you know like yes it it comes
away it's that feeling but I also wanted
to feel nice I also wanted to maybe mean
something to other people you know
potentially maybe people would want to
buy one of those lamps
I wouldn't sell any of my lambs as
right now because they're not ready
they're prototypes and can we go to next
pictures yeah
funny funny thing about this one so that
was the first lamp when I made it I was
like I can't take pictures of it at home
because that wouldn't be the right
setting so I went through an
anthropology store and just placed it
there and took pictures at anthropology
store this they were very amiable and
very supportive of it yes they were like
beautiful did you make that and I
honestly think that one of those lamps
it would be lovely to sell them at
anthropology at some point so then I
went on there's so many places that
would yeah I we enjoyed this especially
in the homes and the offices yeah yeah
thank you yeah yeah this it also is so
many people are looking for something
that is that can bring them to nature
and I think when we're spending 90% of
our time indoors seeing things like this
can really make us smile and ties for
sure for sure yes and it's also very
organic shape like there's nothing
modern about it that isn't the base the
also another interesting thing to
potentially do would be to see if there
could be like a little like scent that's
actually I used to like it so that it
smells like fuel on you or something
so then I went on to create more lamps
because you know I got the momentum
going I want to make more of them and
this one was my thesis project so to
speak I think people think of thesis
projects as like the final thing that
you do in school but I think I think we
should always work on thesis projects
right we we have at any single at any
point in life we have something to say
you know if you were a creative person
you you always have something to say you
want to slick spit it out into the world
but you have to do it in a deliberate
way which is why this project is so
useful so I made this project I made
this for about three months I was just
working on this
you know hands-on and I tried to perfect
my technique I tried to refine my color
scheme I tried to make it a marketable
product and most importantly I really
tried to set a mouse to set the next
stepping stone for me you know I made
this but I want to move on you know
that's in the that's in a certain way in
this in some way it's in the past
like I want to move on what's the next
step gonna be yeah so then I developed
this this is project with five lambs and
can we click a little bit more and this
one is a cherry I name them all after
lyrics of Lana Del Ray songs because I
love Lana don't we this is okay you also
you are also dealing with things like
making sure that they're you know safe
but like electrically and stuff like
that yes because there are very
important things to be thinking about
and I'm glad that you were able to
figure out that it is yeah yeah it is
very important especially if I want to
sell them I mean I use it I use it every
day and I know that it doesn't get hot
at all because as LED light and felt is
actually it requires huge temperature to
even set it on fire yeah so I know that
it's not going to catch fire have
confidence in that but I wanted to make
sure so I contacted a lot of people who
are like electrical engineers and stuff
like that and they all proved that you
know it's not gonna catch on fire so
we're good yeah yeah and that's this
project is also how I develop this
affection and love for flowers I mean
when you come when you see it like at
the other side of your room just
standing there it really does look like
a real flower and it just brings so much
joy into my life and I don't understand
how flowers are just so beautiful
they're just so beautiful they don't
have to prove anything to anybody you
know they're just they're just gorgeous
like I just love that I wonder if anyone
doesn't like flowers I doubt that
there's like anyone that is like I hate
flowers I'd be like wait why yeah
there's another good quote I was telling
you earlier it's at the earth laughs and
flowers I love that quote I love that
quote system flowers and there's so many
flowers they make us so happy they smell
so good
they're also really important for the
ecosystems of bees and their pollination
exactly yeah yeah insects to to reside
on and within and yeah rose gardens are
amazing places for humans to go yeah
this was my wine Rosalind I also did did
make a point to make to post edit the
pictures so that it looks better than
the actual prototypes I because you know
as a designer I want to keep the
momentum going which means I have to
inspire myself I have to think of my art
better than it actually is
I can't be a realist like if you if you
if you're an artist you can't be a
realist to certain degree you can but
you need to look further down the line
and be like I want to be there and you
need to see every artwork as a potential
for something greater you know when you
have a blank piece of paper you can't be
oh I can't draw I really like the last
one was shed I can't I can't really make
it happen you can't approach a painting
with that mentality you need to think
about this is masterpiece to be
discovered how do I make it happen
you know that's why that's where
dreaming comes in you I dream a lot I
dream out loud every time I bike I speak
to myself yeah because I'd reach that
time I dream every time I'm at home by
myself I talked to myself and I express
what I want to get out of life that's
how I dream I dream on paper i dreamin
felt I just basically
things up like that's that's the that's
the mean like aspect of my art I think
is I just dream out loud and that's what
the dream my dreams look like my Rose
got in dreams and then that gives you a
that becomes part of the North Star part
yeah and then you set your steps to get
to those locations and I think that's
exactly how old isn't it did it I mean
how else would you do that if what what
he did like his cartoons he did it in in
the Great Depression you can't be a
realist during the Great Depression
everything sucks there is no money there
are poor children on the streets you
know like you can't be a realist so you
have to be a dreamer and that's how you
read people beautiful places because if
you can he said it if you can dream it
you can make it go something like that
and it really is a mentality that is
still exists in the company and it still
inspires me so greatly if I can think
about it yeah I can make it happen you
know yeah that's so so beautiful I'm
just I'm also so happy to now you know
better be able to take in the different
pieces of you that I think you know made
you into who you are today and I think
can help so many other kids around the
world that care a lot about art to
surround themselves with will get to
these communities of art as well in a
little bit but the idea of having people
around to your parents or people in your
community other kids that you can make
art with that you can find really
inspirational people like Walt Disney
these these these experiences that
really move you to to pursue things that
that you care about making and actually
going and physically doing it like you
dream it and then like physically go and
make it yeah and you have to do things
like sketch to find the nuances and
things and yeah you know become really
good at that and that's I like that a
lot those those components totally make
a lot of sense about you know who you
are yeah yeah totally and community
matters a lot
should we talk about it let's do let's
do quick on the way so this is so just
quick on the way okay so the the the
seen and felt is the is the body of work
of your art and then the flower lamps
are one component of that yes correct
and these are prototypes but soon you're
looking to potentially help get them in
for for people to who want to bring them
into their homes or into their offices
and things like potentially but it's
really not the cornerstone of what I do
it really is just like a cherry on top
like oh it would be nice if sometimes I
could make money of it but honestly I
don't that's not what I live for
I live for to capture life's most
beautiful moments and capture it so that
it creates more beautiful moments you
know so that it just like builds on
itself and true like felting is just one
of the things that I expressed that I
also do a lot of paintings let's do it
oh sure okay
so I painted this oil painting of this
oil painting of rose from Titanic yeah
because it is my favorite absolutely
favorite movie and I I couldn't tell you
how many times I've watched it it's
probably thousands at this point no way
yes I was I technically way too much
just on look like it would end like for
our movie with and and I would just like
started over literally I yeah yeah
that's that's how I used to watch it and
I would always watch it in the
background when I was like making art as
a child but what I really love about
roses character is this like she knew
what she wanted and Jack helped her
uncover what what she actually wanted
you know by the end of the movie she
doesn't need any money she doesn't need
this horrible husband fiance she doesn't
need that freaking diamond thing
she doesn't need even her would like to
be of
with her mom like she sacrifices the
relationship with her mom just so that
she can be herself and I not the mom
part but I really respect that I just
really respect that you know who you are
and you just go for it
yeah just go for a lot of challenges
that are like families it might be a
challenge friends might be a challenge
money might be a challenge yes but these
are tests of faith yes yes exactly and
when they those challenges come you just
have to stay aligned yeah
you just have to this is hard work this
is hard work
what are you putting how you put this
together but it was also you know like
there is a great deal of technique that
goes into creating like a realistic
painting like this like it goes and
layers like the first layer for example
is green like her face is green it looks
morbid and I used the very old
Renaissance technique to paint this but
this is another line of those things
that I make to just like didn't refine
or define myself define who I am what
influences me just to like ruminate on
all of those thoughts it's very very
important and I think sometimes it is
seen as a selfish thing which is a wrong
way to see it everything you do is a
selfish thing but also it's not a
selfish thing you just you have to know
who you are before you have anybody else
I think we're all good with that
right yeah like you just you just can't
go on pretending like you're somebody
else or conforming to something that
you're not yeah so yeah I'm sure she's
just a role model for me
I love how Rose is a role model for you
and I love the story that you're sharing
with us about her and don't you love her
name too Rose I know how synergistic is
the universe sometimes Rose exactly
those little signs some people say those
are the signs that you are on the right
path on your
star path yes yes exactly so this is
what I mean I just want to say like the
amount of detail here it's just so cool
like a little little like reflection in
the eyes yeah and just like how much how
hard it is to make every hair every
eyelash every eyebrow every nuance and
color of skin and honestly it's so real
like honestly looking at this I'm like I
could do so much better if I were to do
it again that's badass that's what's up
that's enough I love that yes yes that's
oil that is oil yes and I really don't
like I really don't like just like
cornering myself into one technique like
I'm an artist like I I want to express
something at all it all starts with what
do I want to say to the world about my
past
or just like my corny or who I am what
do I want to say not to anybody in
particular just just to myself you know
sitting in the room Who am I that's
where it all starts and then the
technique comes in and then I can use a
variety of mediums it can be graphic
design it can be a digital like movie it
can be a watercolor painting I really
don't like cornering myself which is why
it's so hard to define myself as like I
only do watercolor no I don't like I
don't only do felt lamps although it is
easier for people to grasp oh it's like
oh it's a delegation that's problems but
Adelie also does so many other things
Adele here is just an artist and I just
that that's that's Graham I am an artist
and when you get really good at a bunch
of different art techniques they stack
into and on top of each other and it
helps you see art in completely new ways
that if you were just super deep and
just one technique you won so exactly
exactly like the multidisciplinary learn
different disciplines together and this
case different art techniques yeah
exactly
so then okay so the another component is
oil oil paintings and then you also have
watercolor paints yes all right let's
okay cuz these are these and you do
these so often like your your Instagram
page is so cool everyone needs to go and
follow a bilious Instagram page there's
so many examples how are you yeah we are
we're showing some of that right now
and it's just so cool that there's so
many like examples of you just being
able to see something and then just put
it into watercolor and like they're
they're gorgeous like it of course
there's tons of flowers here there's
tons of landscapes this one of the
Seacliff area is so beautiful to like I
love this one a lot like you just did
such a good job and it's just I love it
I love it and I really noticed that a
watercolor fifty percent of a painting
success is what the mentality that you
go into it you know I tried it a couple
of times I was like oh I'm gonna create
beautiful paintings for Instagram nah
doesn't work that way I wouldn't even
post that painting that's how bad it
usually turns out the important thing
for me is to go into it and be like I
want like I'm going through something in
life something hard and I need closer
alignment you know I noticed that when I
had certain crisis at work for example
like I hated my work I cried every
single day for like hours at work you
know I hated my work I would come home
and I would I would go into the park for
example and I would find flowers and I
would paint those flowers it would
momentarily allow me to something that I
ought to do yes you know I don't need to
think about all this
stuff that just you know all those
challenges all those things that you
have no control over really I don't need
to think about them I just need to think
about where do I need to go what does it
take to get there and flowers just
happen to be one of those things that
they point me the right way every time
so I paint a lot of flowers which camera
should I envision yeah this one's good
yeah so I I paint a lot of flowers it
usually takes about 30 minutes maybe
okay so I can adorn them - Wow and
there's all my art is observational it's
not abstract I don't do abstract I do
observational because it is very
important for me to ground myself you
know like I as I mentioned before I need
to see things I need to see them clearly
and I need to be honest with what I see
you can be dishonest in watercolor mmm
again like you can't be dishonest
you have to be so honest with like what
you see because that's how you will get
that will ISM you know the life does not
work by your your rules you know you
can't impose them on you anything these
are so beautiful
thank you so what does thought when you
do have these moments that you're
capturing like Earth's beauty in a sense
then what what are you what are you
feeling when you're doing this I feel
again that sense of belonging yeah you
know just like when I went to Disney
World for the first time I felt like oh
my god this is where I'm supposed to be
and every time when I have anxiety at
like anywhere anxiety about oh I'm not
I'm not quite doing what I'm supposed to
be doing like that feels wrong and we're
like that social dynamic was a bit I
don't know like I didn't feel myself
doing that
and painting flowers just grounds me and
it's not like I'm escaping that I'm
actually thinking every time I pain than
you think
yes every time I'm painting anything I'm
thinking deeply about those things that
are going on with my life and in a sense
that's how I practice life you know I'm
just not I don't I really hate you and
anger like anger about something you
know like Oh like I'm not paid enough
I'm underpaid and then I just like all
those toxic sauce I just like keep keep
flowing so when I do paint those toxic
thoughts they just they they lose their
toxic component like they just become
one of those challenges in life that
they just go through but since I'm like
I know that I'm on the right right path
just by doing it yeah so like I'm
secured that I'm doing I'm going through
things that I ought to be doing and life
life just goes on like life is life I
can you know I can't make it prettier or
better I can just change my perception
about it really and that's how I change
my perception or attitude about it I
hope that we can structure a social
fabric in the future where it's easy for
people to do easier for people for kids
especially to do what they love and not
necessarily even have to go somewhere
else where they don't find themselves in
flow just so they can have a couple
hours of flow after I think that's
ridiculous
oh yeah yes to not be here so much in
the past when we were in our more
formative years of our origins of our
species and now it's it's almost the
toxicity of the of the system that we've
developed that is pushing us in the
direction so just you're a role model
for people to be able to pursue this in
the
that they have to yeah to align
themselves at the North Star
yeah can we see some of the others also
these are so beautiful thank you
so these ones okay I do a lot of like
interior sketching and these ones I did
at this Victorian hotel in Vancouver
called amethyst in you should yes you
know I'm trying to match my everything
in my life yes good and you know like I
saw them I it's a Victorian hotel and
Victorian era is known to be very highly
ornamental right so it's pretty
difficult to draw ornamental stuff and
that's why it was so you know
challenging but like very pleasantly
challenging for me to draw love this
because there's so much going on but
what did you concentrate on and how do
you say how did you tell the truth
without overwhelming with information
you know like I wanted to capture of how
it felt in that hotel and honestly that
that's my boyfriend working well he was
working I was I was running around the
hotel in painting yeah I've never done
as many paintings as that one day I
think I did seven paintings in one day
it was it was the best day of my life
yeah yeah my life my life Wow and you
know it means so much to me because
again I captured it on paper it's mine
now but also while capturing all of that
I hated myself on Victorian on Victorian
aesthetics on how it felt to be in the
place like that and honestly after after
visiting that hotel I was like I'm gonna
have a hotel I'm gonna have a hotel I'm
gonna make it happen whatever whatever
it takes me I'm gonna make it happen I'm
going to have a
and then you get to do all the interior
design I need you to do all the hype of
the first and that's why I do so much
all right because like I can already see
different rooms like there's gonna be
Titanic room absolutely that's a room
that you would go when you had a
horrible day and you feel like the world
is crushing and you are just so
depressed that's where that's the room
that you would go to you know and that's
that painting of course right there um
yeah I just you know right now that
hotel is basically consuming all my all
my headspace that's so cool you just
yeah you meet just a tiny even just one
or two or three rooms just a small thing
to start maybe and then to see if you
could you build it out you could even
probably go on to platforms like Airbnb
and just inquire like with homeowners
and be like hey I know you like we're in
Delft
wow these rooms like you need the like
interior designer those could be nice
little practices also for sure right
there is sonder you know thunder thunder
yeah it's a they also kind of they have
a hotel it's similar to Airbnb but they
have hotels and every nice yeah yeah
like perfect like it's it's my dream
company at this that's your next yeah
like its toes stepping-stone yeah that's
so cool so okay so we got yeah we did
the the flower lamps we got the
watercolors the oil paintings let's talk
about the art communities yes okay so
beat art yes
this is San Francisco's art community go
to art community you guys have such cool
events that you do I loved coming to
your event it was super fun it was a lot
of fun and it's it's four of you total
right it organizes that but we so we
organize events every single Tuesday and
we invite a lot of people and on average
we have nowadays we have about 12 people
on average and we get together every
Tuesday
and we draw something we co-create you
know we practice drawing because again
like dreaming is fun but you have to
have the right level of skills so how do
you work on those skills you know you
got to keep yourself motivated and what
we do with this community is we we we
try to inspire each other really like
not everybody does felt lamps like me
but they do like some crazy abstract
paintings and they're just so into it
and that's how they keep me motivated
you know and it's really it's really an
amazing community I'm so glad that I
found it and that I can be a part of it
it just really means a lot to have
people who do some more things yeah and
specifically what if you could drawing a
lot so you're drawing yes yes and also
just I also want to oh please please um
for pride we we invited the transgender
model and it was it was great like it it
was the best way to celebrate pride for
us for artists you know like it was just
a but you're doing a bunch of different
every Tuesday you're doing every single
every Tuesday you're doing a bunch of
different Willick workshops but also
people just getting together to do their
art and that in itself so I want to just
do a quick bit on the importance of art
community because it's as though that
we're so much moving into like tech
everything that it's it's hard to embed
like art into our communities now it's
like no one is paying me to be an art
organizer no one is paying me you you
know because there's such weird dynamics
around the markets and how they
potentially don't reward certain things
that actually a lot of people are really
interested in so we yeah so like the
of our community like putting people
together that are all really inspired by
art and that can all help each other
motivate each other story tell through
art to get other people inspired to be
right yeah I hear it a lot that it's
it's hard to be an artist in the city
and it is hard I mean yes art is just by
default is not as marketable as like
software engineering you know like it's
not there is a little demand for it like
people don't crave it it's it's a great
add-on to somebody's life but there
there's low demand for it and I
personally think it's fine art has its
own purpose art doesn't have to be
marketable you can make art whatever you
want to make it like for me again it's
it's a way for me to live the life that
I want to live to stay in a momentum if
I have money but I don't have the
momentum I don't know do I need life at
all like I don't know and what we try to
do at the art we actually do have a lot
of people who do work at TACC and I
myself work at attack as well for my
daytime job we don't we don't want to
encourage people be better about it
don't be bitter bitterness will not get
you anywhere far be inspired be art make
what you want to make out of this life
find a way and make it art make it
artistry to find a way around those
sharp corners you know because you know
like flowers they don't bloom I mean
they they can get the right nutrients
and the most porous soil they are
resilient so yes there are many
opportunities for artists there are
actually a lot of opportunities but it's
harder to get opportunities for artists
in San Francisco right now but that's
your poor soil and it's up to you to get
the best out of it get the right
nutrients just don't be bitter just just
don't blame don't point fingers at
techies techies like whatever that means
because they just bring their value to
the world and you have your value to
bring to the world so concentrate on
that yeah and in just in general also
making it easier I think for just
changing our norms around art and making
it a little bit more evidently something
that people care more about and have an
eye more for let's um let's mention on
the future of art where do these things
not only take you but where do you see
art going with the technology industry
and all this type of stuff I think
people are so creative they're so
creative I think it's just a tool
you know like felting it's it's felting
it is a tool it's a technique so you can
find that technique is in a digital
space if you wish to people are crazy
creative I think it's not gonna go
anywhere it's not gonna go anywhere do
you see it specifically maybe going into
like augmented and virtual reality Lily
leveraging art design there may be a
little I'm actually very interested in
that's you are yeah wouldn't it be nice
to like design a world or like flowers
and everything yeah and then you can
walk through and get inspired by it
right so you can basically take what may
be like Disney World is doing and you
can then like replicate at times like
millions of examples of really beautiful
creative night environments that people
could go and through and get
mired by yeah type of thing yeah it
democratized being able to make those
environments yeah for people
yes it's I don't I don't really I don't
think I have enough knowledge of like
the state of art in the world because
again I'm very you know pointed at what
I want to get out of it that's a very
global question yeah I can't answer
Delhi is a very like I've identified a
flower that I will start painting in
watercolor right now that's yeah yes and
I'm like trying to comprehend
macro-level yeah we do need all sorts of
people and I also want to show people
cuz I promised that we would do this I
want to show people what the what the
lamps will look like without are you up
without our stage lights and yeah so
this is what they look like they look
wonderful if you have so it's a very
nice light when you go to sleep and you
know like you don't want a harsh from
transition from full life to lights to
absolutely no like like you don't want
that because then you can hit your pinky
and then it's gonna hurt you know so
this is just the right us light for
going to sleep or any sexy times for me
like it's just sexy time for reading I
can't really have sex attempts without
this without those lamps anymore yeah
yeah they're just like a staple they
contribute to very romantic by different
just by definition it's like a chart
enchanted Rose kind of thing like it's
romantic yeah yeah yeah so we have
reading night light and romance all the
different yeah well you can't really
read but those I mean it depends depends
if you angle it maybe towards your
bookings yeah yeah if you do like that
yeah it's easy
do angle yeah and go well look thank you
Singh they're kissing okay all right and
let's let's all let's wrap on our last
couple questions all right
so adele yet speaking of all this macro
level stuff do you think we're in a
simulation I don't think so
okay tell us why oh my god I hope you
wouldn't ask why we're not in the
simulation
why would we I mean I take life for what
it is and I don't know any other version
of it I'm just trying to make the best
out of it so if if it is a simulation I
would also be fine with that I think I'm
just trying to live my best life in this
simulation or non simulation in this
thing called life yes and then what do
you think the most beautiful thing in
the world would you guess it okay
[Music]
a beautiful peony you know peony the
flower peony yeah it's like it's very
lush and oh my god peonies are so
beautiful they're just the most
beautiful thing in the world how do you
spell it peo n why flower this one yeah
look at that yes you think yes yeah you
so you these are the most beautiful
thing yeah actually this flowers is I
call those they're only interesting yeah
Wow and and you think why is this the
most beautiful thing in the world for me
I mean I can't say for everybody for me
it just means it's a very Victorian
flower it's a very ornate flower so
right now I'm on a Victorian chapter of
my life
I love Victorian aesthetics and I want
to turn my life toward that that way so
for me it just like it lays a path
towards something where I want to go
which is why it's beautiful because my
path is full of beautiful things and I
just chase those things and I just make
them happen wanted today but earlier
what a great episode on the value of art
this yeah it's been so much fun thank
you so much for inviting thank you thank
you everyone for tuning in we greatly
appreciate it we would love to hear your
thoughts in the comments below on the
episode let us know what you're thinking
also do check out the links in the bio
below again that's seen and felt calm as
well as a Delia's Instagram we would
love for you to have more conversations
with your family your friends co-workers
people online on social media about the
importance of the value of art and what
what is it on your journey that you are
taking like why do you make art yeah
yeah and actually going out after as you
dream and making and making and creating
the art into the world doing art
community get going with that everyone
big shout out to Ron Vargas for
producing and directing thank you very
much Ronnie and also everyone support
the artists entrepreneurs the organizers
in your communities the scientists the
spiritual leaders support them help them
grow help them prosper support
simulation our links are below our
patreon our PayPal our cryptocurrency
link also our merch design link join us
in that effort and go and build the
future everyone manifest those dreams
into the world thank you so much for
tuning in we will see you soon